so jordan i was watching uh this little
indie film last night it's called star
wars yeah i've heard of it yeah it's uh
it's pretty cool one thing in the movie
that's you know the storm troopers are
you familiar with them yes yes yes that
is ringing a bell these guys shoot
their blasters a lot but they don't
really land many hits we keep seeing the
same cast of characters in a hail of
gunfire over and over and over
statistically
that's not gonna happen statistically
someone someone's gonna get shot yeah
well you know like i was just thinking
about like god got a new pair of glasses
and clearly eyesight has to be an issue
there you know those those lasers are
probably really bright they're probably
getting flash blindness imagine laser
pointers just constantly it's not going
to do good things for you yeah it kind
of makes you wonder why was the empire
sending these stormtroopers into battle
almost legally blind yeah i've always
suspected it's a lack of proper
healthcare coverage it's funny because
it's such a structural superpower and
yet they're so deficient in so many
areas it's like america
oh
he just got here too the storm troopers
they don't have universal healthcare
they don't i think you're right the
stormtroopers don't i think it's all
privatized
on the death star
then maybe that's the issue right that's
why the empire failed
they didn't
you know invest in their people yeah han
solo after he's thought out from the
carpenter he's blind he cannot see but
you know what the rebels they care about
their troops han's eyesight came back oh
my god he's a sharp shooter i truly
believe that the rebels end up winning
because they had a great healthcare
program within their within their ranks
and i think that's why the empire lost
if you're a storm trooper you must be
sitting there wondering like who who
cares about me who cares well
i care
i care i care i care i care it's a pun
i got lasik myself
and the procedure was terrifying okay
they cut my eyes open and i was awake
but i'll tell you what i'm glad i did it
because i can see
well
ish i would do that again in a heartbeat
i'd say emperor palpatine pin me down
and cut me open because i want to see
what i'm shooting this war doesn't need
to be as long as it is we don't need to
lose as many soldiers as we do let's try
and imagine a world where stormtroopers
have great eyesight and the impact that
would have what does that look like what
is that what does that war look like
that's a world i want to live in
it's a world we can create
together
you want me to hold it i can hold it
you know what jordan we should make a
little video to right this wrong we can
go through and we can almost take the
trilogy
compact it and just make it the shortest
war of all time because end of the day
if they're hitting their shots there's
only like six people we have to take out
to kind of end the war they hit luke
they hit leia they hit han rebellion
done
death star totally fine the first one
it's fine no need for a rebuild that's
good i love the angle of you know darth
vader he's been he's had some health
issues himself he's missing a couple
legs missing a couple arms severely
burned being part of the empire you know
it cost him an arm and a leg so
that's comedy that's comedy
darth's like the relatable boss he cares
about the troops because he's been there
he's been through it so vader will give
the troopers the healthcare they need
and then i'm thinking just death
compilation and in houdini there's
something that i've been wanting to
build which is there's some new ragdoll
tools in houdini 19
and this feels like the perfect
opportunity to just take all the models
of these star wars characters
ragdoll the heck out of them and just
start throwing bodies
i think maybe we bring back
luke skywalker we know what nico can do
when he takes dean's perfect little
mark hamill face and really looks it up
great so we got a game plan we're gonna
dive into the edit first find the scenes
that we need to build this thing out uh
start scouring the internet for some
assets to actually make this thing
possible
and uh finally give these stormtroopers
the healthcare they deserve
so in our last video together fender
taught me a little bit about nuke and it
only feels right that i repay you by
teaching you a little bit about houdini
oh how to turn tables
as the saying goes in this short we have
a lot of different characters that we
want to kill off but we have a very
funny idea for lando and it's ironically
the perfect opportunity for you to get
your hands wet
feet wet bloody for you to get your
hands bloody on some of this simulation
work so the idea here is that lando
looks up and in the distance tie
fighters are on their way and they're
accurate shots so they hit you know
they're gonna hit it we're gonna throw
them off the top of this ship and uh i
figure i'll give you the rundown of the
houdini ragdoll system because arguably
the most powerful thing inside of
houdini is its ability to handle complex
simulations there is a new pretty
comprehensive set of tools in the new
houdini 19 and you can do some really
powerful and cool things we're going to
ragdoll lando calrissian what we can do
is
isolate this geometry
and
clip the geometry so i can literally
just cut his legs off oh the poor boy
and the poor boy and then when i plug it
into the deform here well guess what
everything still works exactly as it
should oh that's awesome so the full
animation the full ragdoll is now
legless he looks like lieutenant duhan
and dan
okay so now we have a pipeline to rag
all these characters when they get hit
by these newly accurate stormtroopers
but you might be wondering where did you
get all these high-res models of these
star wars characters
thanks to our
bells in russia
yeah thanks to our friends in russia all
the models for the star wars universe
from star wars battlefront 2 are online
and available for download for free you
just have to click on buttons that are
in russian and you don't necessarily
know what you're agreeing to but it's
worth it the models already look amazing
we just basically have to bring them
into blender and basically rebuilding
out the textures and shading
we got to find some creative ways to
kill off these characters they can't
just all get shot in the head you know
that only lasts for so long before it
gets boring so you get a character
that's covered in hair like chewbacca
gotta light that son of a gun up y'all
y'all have been to burning man there's a
whole there's a whole other step up
burning vodka
have you seen him with hit without hair
though for all of you who have been
curious about what chewbacca looks like
under the fur we have an answer and it
may upset you
look at this beast burn it
look at this thing are those teeth chewy
come on have you ever seen a face that
that has been asking to be burned more
than this one so we'll be running the
fire simulation for this shot of chewie
in a program called embryogen you guys
actually might remember the first time
that we ever used emojin at corridor was
for ren's first satisfying some say
unsatisfying render of his smoky head on
his front lawn it's incredible a
borderline real-time fire simulator
there's a ton of presets right out the
gate it's very very intuitive to use and
fenner shot me in fbx just basically an
animation of the chewbacca model
flailing and falling to the ground and i
was able to import that into emerging
and just light that puppy up just
immediately and it looks really good you
know after playing with some shading
settings i bounced him out some
different passes the fire you know the
smoke different lighting passes and you
know being the wizard that he is he's
able to composite it really quickly into
the scene and it looks great so far
okay so fenner i have something to show
you as well this is this is kind of one
of our hero deaths right this is one
that we really build up to and so it
needs to be satisfying in its own
uniquely horrific way basically there's
a line and a new hope where han is
sitting there talking to greedo and he
says over my dead body and you know what
i think he's just kind of asking for it
so yeah comedy dictates that's when he
has to die and of course there's a lot
of debate over who shot first right but
we want to introduce a third party into
this the stormtroopers right they're
going to settle the debate no one shoots
first they shoot them both let's rap
this out all right they're accurate now
we finish this war's over so essentially
what we need to do is we need to explode
han's head peter has done some head
explosions here before that are
definitely the inspiration for this so
i'm going to pay homage in my own way
and so what we have to do is we have to
build a layered head from the ground up
basically and i'm no doctor but i know
three things there's skin on a head
there's a brain in a head most times and
there's a skull inside of houdini we've
layered these things right we have the
head of han solo
and inside of the head i went ahead and
designed this chunky bloody skull
inside the skull we've got the brain
harrison ford's actual brain it was it
was his actual brain so big there's also
of course el house in heads which is
spanish for eyes we've got the main
eyeball we've got the cover for the eye
and we've got the stem
the eye stem and this is this is bad
this is bad science or bad biology
because i don't think the eyes built
like this at all but uh it's all we need
really to hang on because i want the
eyeball to pop out and dangle this is
something that peter's done in the past
and i love it i've always wanted to do
it so after i simulate the eyeball i'll
pre-fracture the brain and the skull and
tie those pieces together with what are
called constraints these constraints are
just basically polygon lines that
connect from one piece to another and
inform them that they are bound to that
object unless a certain force breaks
their bond and that's the way that this
rigid body simulation stuff works and so
i'm introducing a big force on the
inside of the head to break all those
constraints and explode the head
outwards
and after that simulated i'll layer on
yet another simulation for the goofy
blood explosion
so it should be like pretty horrific
that's certainly the goal and again you
know i'm really excited to see what
fenner can do with these elements in
comp to make it even worse for all of
you
because that's what we do we're trying
to make it as nasty as possible
hey welcome to kashyyyk chris and i are
actually stormtroopers but ever since we
got accurate there's not really much to
do daddy vader up there sent us down to
hunt some wookies now darth vader's a
bit forgetful but luckily today's
sponsor bespoke post has us covered
they've supplied us with everything we
need for a successful hunting trip
bespoke post is a monthly membership
club which delivers awesome boxes of top
shelf goods from under the radar brands
so every month they introduce cool new
boxes that have new products of outdoor
gear home and kitchen goods clothing and
more each box has like 70 dollars worth
of goods inside but only cost you a
fraction of that because we got the bean
here which is
a super sick headlamp which i'm about to
pull out every month you get something
cool i have this watch that's from
bespoke too so christian has us covered
on lighting but what are we gonna do
when we actually catch a wookie we're
gonna have to chop up the meats somehow
chop them up luckily one of the boxes
that bespoke sent us was this terra box
and it comes with this sweet japanese
inspired survival knife once i use my
knife to skin them and get the meat then
we have to smoke them
that's where this next bespoke box comes
really in handy everything you need to
smoke and fuse your cocktails your meats
your cheeses and sausage
way nicer than anything on the death
star
so what's really cool is every month you
get to preview the box that they assign
you based on your preferences and you
can one keep it to swap it for another
box or three you can skip the month
entirely for no charge you only pay for
what you want and it's really cool
because their box lineup constantly
changes each month you can get twenty
percent off your first purchase if you
click the link in the description and
enter the code quarter crew 20 or go to
bespokepost.com
quarter crew 20. i swear to god they
have really cool stuff go check it out
so we've been making great progress on
this video jordan's kicking out some
amazing simulations from houdini i've
been just trying to rip through as many
shots as i can in nuke tons of comp
shots some cg stormtroopers we've got
some awesome darth vader stuff another
thing i've been really trying to do is
dial in the look of these cg renders to
try to emulate the filmic look of the
original trilogy
we're now at a point where we need to
start shooting our own practical
elements our own plates to use so we're
going to be shooting jordan doing our
motion capture for darth vader which
we'll be using deep motion for we will
be revamping our stormtrooper benefits
program
what is this voice where did this voice
come from
and we're going to be shooting with sam
and nico on our brand new green screen
for our x-wing cockpit shots so as long
as everything keeps going this smoothly
i think we should be all good for the
deadline here
we got a serious problem here
our main man jordan
he's stuck in my homeland
they won't let him out i think we gotta
call him and find out what happened
what are you doing up there bro okay so
i've been on vacation in montreal it's
been great had a great time and i was
going to board my flight but before you
board your flight you have to take a
cover test lo and behold bro i i tested
positive right as i was going through
security so
they literally escorted me
via security out of the airport so i had
a police escort out of the airport and
then they just said just go just go
somewhere and and hide in a hole for
five days so i've been hiding in that
whole recovery dang man and uh it's kind
of freaky when you're not when you're in
another country
and you are not feeling good yeah it's
kind of it's kind of freaky man
especially when you're not allowed to
see any doctors
they straight up told me they're like we
can't have you see the doctors you know
medicare or something but i'm not
allowed to enjoy the free healthcare so
i have to stop right now this is a
perfect parallel this is how the
stormtroopers feel when they don't have
eye care coverage it's not right so just
cross your fingers for me that i can
escape yeah man
you escaped canada so do you have any
any advice for me i mean what should i
do i don't know man you got you need
those like those uh cool bro border
security guards that i ran into
what awful timing too like we were
feeling so comfortable and confident
with that two weeks we had left yeah man
it's too bad you're not here like we've
got this um the deep fake shot coming up
so it'd be awesome to get your help on
that but
we'll try to do it without you
i think i think for this occasion i i
think we're all just thankful that
nico's not trapped in montreal as well
yeah man i'm just trying to come home
that's my mission man i just gotta get
back so we can push really hard next
week and just get it done we'll uh feel
better and uh
cross my fingers for you for friday dude
thank you brother me too right on all
right later jordan
[Music]
looks like we got to call in the big
guns
i'm ready
so there's two scenes in this piece that
we're gonna be using the deep fake luke
for one is right after luke has been
rescued and he's just waking up in the
med bay and the other we're gonna put
him in his actual x-wing cockpit we'll
have his jumpsuit the helmet and
everything so we sat dean down from the
green screen we shot our med-base scene
and next up was our x-wing scene so by
removing the visor
my face is perfectly exposed so now we
can apply the deep fake right in this
little region
it's gonna look great
so now that we've shot our green screen
footage of dean we can take the amazing
deep fake model that nico has trained up
for that mandalorian video and apply it
onto our footage that we've shot
we're going to fire up this luke
skywalker deep fake and get her running
there it is nice that looks
shockingly good already
yeah it's really really nice deep vegas
holy crap
man this is
insanely impressive
hey look at that skin detail yeah
seriously like the little moles and his
little scar details man i forgot how
good this looked i'm really happy with
it
we should we should do more luke
skywalker cameos yeah man
i forgot that we have a luke skywalker
filter yeah
i think you know compared to the most
recent luke deep fake like the quality
of this deep fake's not that far off
so niko's walked me through the deep
fake process here and everything's
looking really good it kind of blows my
mind that this isn't actually mark
hamill that's just the deep fake that's
actually dean it's bizarre so you can
see there's some you know blend issues
with the forehead and that sort of thing
the color doesn't match exactly but
that's where our comp work comes in
[Music]
so the next step after we had our deep
fake applied is that i ran the original
plate through keen tools program face
tracker and face builder in nuke which
basically gives us a cg model of dean's
face
and gives us the tracking of the actual
head so the reason we did this face
track is so that we have dean's head
motion and face motion so that we're
able to basically tie our cg visor and
chin strap in and make it look like it's
part of the helmet and mimicking the
motion that dean is making in all the
plates and what's really nice about this
is we have all the different lighting
reflections on the visor with all the
little smudges and kind of surface
imperfections on the visor that are
there in the battlefront models which
are again just shouting out the artists
at dice they're incredible so using the
alpha of the visor here we're able to
kind of cast some of that orange
kind of lighting onto our defects face
to make it look like you know there's
actually light being shown through the
visor and that it's getting a little bit
of that orange yellow lighting onto
luke's face here so one thing that i
think really helps kind of sell our deep
fake in this is
having a object in front of it that's
something that deep fakes can't really
emulate that well at this point they can
sometimes do glasses but you need to
really train it with the original
footage of them wearing those exact
glasses and it's still going to look
kind of you know janky it's not going to
have that 3d perspective that we're
getting here so
having this kind of the cg visor and the
cg chin strap it actually sort of helps
hide some of the imperfections that are
in our deep fake i think it looks pretty
good it's not going to ever be perfect
but i think you would look at this and
you'd be like oh hey that's luke which
that's kind of what we're going for here
i'm really happy with how this deep fake
turned out i think it's a nice little
kind of final act reveal for the video
you know we're still down a man but
we've been making really good progress
on this and i'm really really hoping
that we can just push through and get
this video done in time for this weekend
with star wars celebration because we
want to you know really celebrate our
stormtroopers and give them the
healthcare that they deserve
so the time is finally here we finished
the video just in time for star wars
celebration this weekend and our boy is
finally back
honey i'm home
i literally had to hop on a bus to cross
the border to be here in time to finish
this video the entire time that i was in
captivity in canada i was concerned that
we weren't going to meet this deadline
and ren graciously stepped in to help us
carry that baton forward
but here we are so just super pumped
really happy with the final product and
it's thanks to everyone here who all
played a part in their own unique and
beautiful way if it's anything like the
last videos it's gonna be amazing wow
bar said hi yeah let's just hit play man
i'm i'm dying to see the final let's see
how this looks
[Music]
what do you think this is all about i
don't know he never tells us anything
morning boys so a few of you have raised
concerns over our lack of eye care
coverage and trust me i get it when
pelpi has assured me that we will be
revamping our stormtrooper benefits
program hell yeah brother you get 20 20
vision you will get 20 20 visions
everybody gets 20 20 pigeons
here we go
i got them
[Music]
[Music]
i thought you said gun
i can't wait to tell boss we got luke
and leia
there's the old man take him out
scallywags
so uncivilized
[Music]
let me just leave this party
[Music]
[Music]
are there instructions here
[Music]
hey bro check this out
360 no scope
[Music]
[Music]
come on where are you stupid furball hey
check it out there it is watch and learn
rookie
[Music]
[Music]
headshots bro i could spot that lip
bookie from a mile away
[Music]
oh jeez how are we going to tell him
that all of his friends are dead relax
he is waking up well luke this is
awkward but you are our only hope
seriously
they're all dead
geez this rebellion's useless
ah careful that's my lightsaber hand
it's just you and our two left and those
two rookie pilots over there these two
rookies
well i guess it's just us three against
the empire is it cool our two rides on
my x-wing
okay this is red leader this is red
komodo standing by red scarlet's
standing by just stick with me and stay
in formation we're gonna be fine quick
question uh i heard there's a tiny guy
inside of r2d2 any chance i'll be able
to meet him
[Music]
oh watch out for those star
them they're trek
my six this is nothing like the
simulations
don't worry the forces on earth that's a
good trick
oh [ __ ] that's like it's just me and r2
and you too luke
all right the trench is coming up you
can count on me luke yeah be advised we
have rebel fighters in the trenches
these stormtroopers are ruining
everything
only one river left
luke
use the force shut up the old one
you're dead
i'm almost there i'm gonna launch my
tormentor in three two
oh yeah
wow okay so we won
uh honestly happened a lot faster than i
expected so uh yeah set blasters to fun
blue builds on me
[Applause]
was that your voice theme yeah that's
your oh my god your one-liners are so
good it's like ah that's my lightsaber
hand
it's like what dude it was so much it
was it got it literally got better and
better and better that is so good
there's so many shots how many shots did
you guys do for this i think it's over a
hundred one-third the number of the
effect shots that are in a new hope
i mean the one shot that definitely
stood out though the the firing range
with like the paper
yeah that was good
i guess you're hot off that satisfying
render with uh like all the like cloth
sam now freaking han's head
going away who did my one question who
put the mustache on
yeah okay
that
was like truly the best touch because it
was completely unnecessary yeah yeah
yeah
that's actually henry cavill's mustache
we cut it out and put it on han solo's
face oh my god it's
so many layers of course shout out to
nick aka shrimp nick for uh for the
awesome edit that he put together for
this video special shout out to natalie
for creating the awesome props we used
in the x-wing shoot and if you guys want
to learn more about that check out
crewcuts on quarterdigital.com and uh
huge shout out to casey and kevin who
helped with all the score and the sound
design for the video they absolutely
killed it and if you guys want to see
this as a standalone video just by
itself hop over to youtube.com corridor
it's living there for you we had a ton
of fun making this video and we got
quite a few more ideas for stuff we want
to do in the future but if you guys have
any ideas we read the comments so leave
a comment below
please inspire us may the force be with
you